what
we are with lanier dominguez who is
currently tied for second place lanier
there's a dangerous moment in the game
at the very end right here it looks like
there was a case of mutual blindness as
uh rook takes e4 look like it's winning
for black did you see this yeah no i
didn't see it uh during the game i just
found out now that uh yeah after i
thought of course bishop takes a five
rook four brook gg7 but i of course
missed that rook ff5 and then
black is winning so yeah i don't know
i felt that i was that i had
compensation of course here but uh yeah
i completely
missed this i was very lucky that uh he
missed it as well
it's somewhat strange or interesting the
pattern of taking the rook off the back
rank yeah it's probably
visually it looks uh like white is doing
well that's why we both
missed it probably
you're in a tie for a second
tomorrow
uh you could make a big dent in the
tournament as you're playing against
wesley
yeah it's uh of course uh
uh crucial game so
i'll i'll try to just
do my best and see what happens i have
black which is
kind of not the best but it's a
situation where you just have to play
the game and forget about the
the result
all right okay we'll let you go as we
have time pressure in another game good
luck tomorrow thank you uh just a quick
question lanier i want to bring up the
game that's going on right now it's the
game uh between derek and richard your
quick knee-jerk reaction would you
prefer to play white or black or would
you prefer to have 30 seconds
looks like white is uh
it's
very safe now because uh black's king is
slightly more
expensive exposed d4 played
for
the
i mean when your opponent's in time
trouble it's these surprise moves rook
d4 you still feel the same way
yeah probably
black's king is anyway a bit exposed
there okay so rook takes d4
pawn takes d4 thank you lanier and whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
takes d4
queen takes h3
i was thinking queen f3 but no queen
takes h3 on the board g3 it's not a
perpetual if you take on g3 i hide
because the e3 square is going to be the
question is what's your thoughts now
linear are you doing
i mean
it's very concrete like after ed4 i
don't know rook d4 seems possible uh
but also maybe some moves like queen b2
i think i still think that uh black is
in some
some
danger here or potentially could be
dangerous because of the king
i don't see what black is doing
concreting concretely on on g3
wow okay ice cream thank you
guys thank you
so much you got nothing
i like that movie queen b2 a loss by
richard